>> Greg: AN AMAZING THING TOOK
PLACE WEDNESDAY.
THE SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICER IN
ILLINOIS TAPPED A 19-YEAR-OLD
GUNMAN AND A HIGH SCHOOL SAVING
COUNTLESS LIVES.
WHEN THE SUSPECT STARTED
SHOOTING NEAR THE SCHOOL GYM,
THE OFFICER CONFRONTED HIM,
CHASED HIM, SHOT HIM.
>> I CANNOT BE MORE PROUD OF THE
POLICE OFFICER AND WHEN HE
RESPONDED TO THE SITUATION.
SHOTS RINGING OUT IN THE
HALLWAYS OF THE SCHOOL, HE
CHARGED TOWARD THE SUSPECT AND
CONFRONTED HIM HEAD-ON.
BECAUSE OF HIS HEROIC ACTIONS,
COUNTLESS LIVES WERE SAVED.
WE ARE FOREVER INDEBTED TO HIM
FOR HIS SERVICE AND BRAVERY.
>> Greg: THE OBVIOUS QUESTION
IS WHY ISN'T THIS ALL OVER THE
NEWS?
SOMEONE ONCE SAID NEWS ISN'T
JUST WHAT HAPPENS.
IT'S WHAT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
THE PROBLEM IS IN THIS CASE THE
MEDIA ISN'T INTERESTED IN WHAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN.
LIVES WERE SAVED THANKFULLY SO
THE STORY DIDN'T FIT THE
NARRATIVE.
THE PRESS MOVED ON TO OTHER
NONHAPPENING THINGS LIKE
COLLUSION.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S GOOD NEWS THAT
THIS WASN'T A BIG STORY.
BUT IT'S ALSO BAD NEWS THAT IT
ISN'T A BIG STORY FOR ITS OWN
SAKE BECAUSE IN THIS NONNEWS
STORY, TRUTH IS REVEALED.
ONE CAN SAVE LIVES BY PROTECTING
PEOPLE.
FOR THE DURATION OF A GUN ATTACK
IS ALWAYS DICTATED FOR THE
ARRIVAL OF THE SECOND GUN.
THIS INCIDENT IS NO EXCEPTION.
LOOK UP THE UNPUBLISHED CDC
REPORT THAT INDICATES NEARLY
2.5 MILLION DEFENSIVE USES OF
GUNS A YEAR.
DIDN'T HEAR ABOUT THAT EITHER?
I DID SAY IT WAS UNPUBLISHED.
I WONDER WHY.
IT'S THE WAY THE PRESS USES
SILENCE SELECTIVELY TO CREATE
ONLY ONE STORY ANGLE THAT
CARRIES THE SEAL OF MEDIA
APPROVAL.
WHICH IS WHY I DID THIS
MONOLOGUE IN THE FIRST PLACE WAS
SOMEONE MIGHT HEAR IT AND YOU
KNOW THE NAME OF MARK DALLAS.
K.G., MARK DALLAS WAS THE
OFFICER.
I FIND IT INTERESTING THE MEDIA
IS INTERESTED IN GUN STORIES
EXCEPT FOR THESE.
>> Kimberly: THEY ARE NOT
INTERESTED IN WHERE GUNS SAVE
LIVES AND ARE USED TO PUT DOWN
SOMEBODY THAT IN FACT WAS TRYING
TO DO HARM.
I LIKE THE WAY YOU ENDED IT.
THAT'S IMPORTANT.
TO KNOW THE NAME OF THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT COMMITTED A
HEROIC ACT AND SAVED LIVES AND
THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT SCHOOLS AND
GUN FREE ZONES AND THINGS LIKE
THAT BETTER VERY, VERY
VULNERABLE, SOFT TARGETS, THINK
ABOUT IT OVER AND OVER.
I HAVE RESPONDED TO SCENES OF
THEIR CRIME.
OFFICER-INVOLVED SHOOTING TEAM.
ANY TIME THERE WAS A DISCHARGE
OF A WEAPON OR SHOOTING LIKE
THAT, THE POLICE HAVE TO GO OUT
ON IT.
YOU SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
YOU GO TO THE SCHOOL AND YOU GO
TO THESE PLACES AND SAY IF ONLY
SOMEONE HAD BEEN ARMED THEY ARE
TO BE ABLE TO DO SOMETHING AND
ACT DECISIVELY, LIVES COULD BE
SAVED.
WEAPONS ARE USED IN MANY
INSTANCES AND WARS TO CREATE
PEACE ULTIMATELY.
>> Greg: THE LEFT USES EVERY
STORY IS SOME KIND OF POLITICAL
TOOL.
THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT IS AN
ARGUMENT FOR MORE GUNS IN
SCHOOLS WE DON'T REALLY HEAR
THAT.
>> Dana: PART OF THE REASON IS
BECAUSE IT WORKS.
THE PROCESS THAT WAS IN PLACE
FOR THAT SCHOOL DISTRICT WORKED.
IF THE POLICY WORKS, YOU OFTEN
DON'T WRITE ABOUT IT.
BUT I ALSO THINK IN SOME WAYS
YOU CAN DO WHAT YOU ARE SAYING.
REMEMBER WHEN RAHM EMANUEL SAID
NEVER LET AN OPPORTUNITY GO TO
WASTE.
IT'S TRUE ON THE OTHER SIDE.
IF YOU ARE A LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND WORRIED ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF A SHOOTER IN YOUR
SCHOOL, HAVING AN ARMED RESOURCE
OFFICER COULD ACTUALLY BE YOUR
ANSWER.
>> Greg: JESSE, SHOULD THE
OFFICER NOT HAVE BEEN THERE WITH
A GUN?
SHOULD IT HAVE BEEN A GUN FREE
ZONE?
>> Jesse: THIS OFFICER TO THE
EXACT OPPOSITE OF WHAT THE
OFFICER DID IN PARKLAND.
HE WAITED OUTSIDE.
THIS ONE FOLLOWED PROTOCOL AND
DIRECTLY ADDRESS TO NEUTRALIZE
THE SHOOTER.
YOUR POINT IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
NEWS ISN'T NECESSARILY ABOUT
WHAT YOU COVER.
IT'S ABOUT WHAT YOU DON'T COVER
AND YOUR ASTEROID ANALOGY RINGS
TRUE HERE.
THEY DON'T ALWAYS COVER GOOD
ECONOMIC NEWS FOR THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY DON'T COVER NEWS THAT MIGHT
BENEFIT THE NRA NARRATIVE, AND
THAT'S FINE.
EVERY OUTLET HAS TO MAKE THEIR
OWN EDITORIAL DECISION ABOUT
WHAT THEY DO OR DON'T COVER BUT
WHEN 90% OF THE MEDIA IS LIBERAL
AND 10% ISN'T, THERE IS A LOT OF
IMPACT ABOUT WHAT THAT
90 PERCENT DOES NOT COVER.
IT DOES A DISSERVICE TO THE
READERS AND VIEWERS WHO AREN'T
FULLY INFORMED BEFORE THEY CAN
MAKE A DECISION OR HAVE AN
OPINION.
>> Greg: JUAN, I AM SURE MY
MONOLOGUE CHANGED YOUR MIND
COMPLETELY.
>> Juan: IT FELT TO ME LIKE
SOMEONE HAD A GUN POINTED AT ME.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE FELT THAT
BEFORE.
>> Juan: WHAT'S INTERESTING TO
ME IS NOT THAT IT DOESN'T GET
COVERED.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
IT'S LIKE THE FAMOUS SAYING, WE
DON'T COVER SAFE LANDINGS AND
NATIONAL AIRPORTS.
IT'S NOT TYPICALLY WHAT GETS
COVERED.
BUT YOU MAKE IT INTO A POLICY
ARGUMENT ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
GUNS SHOULD BE IN SCHOOLS AND
CLASSROOMS ALL OVER.
THAT'S WHERE I THINK I DISENGAGE
BECAUSE TO MY MIND, I LOOK AT
STONEMAN, THERE WAS AN ARMED
GUARD.
COLUMBINE, VIRGINIA TECH, PULSE
NIGHTCLUB.
THERE WERE ARMED GUARDS AT THESE
MASS SHOOTINGS.
DID IT STOP THEM?
NO.
LET'S GET AWAY FROM A BUNCH OF
TV PEOPLE.
LET'S ASK THE TEACHERS IN THESE
SCHOOLS.
DO THEY THINK THEY SHOULD HAVE
GUNS, THERE SHOULD BE ARMED
GUARDS?
NO.
WHAT ABOUT THE PARENTS?
PARENTS LOVE KIDS, I THINK WE
CAN ALL AGREE WITH THAT.
PARENTS SAY THEY DON'T WANT
THESE GUNS IN THEIR SCHOOLS.
MAYBE BECAUSE THEY KNOW WHEN
GUNS ARE AROUND, MORE ACCIDENTS,
MORE FATALITIES.
>> Greg: I'VE GOT TO MOVE ON.
MORE GUNS, LESS CRIME.